who did you give that flower to
thank you that's absolutely lovely
it's it's valentine's time of year and
brady has decided that
we should talk about attraction because
attraction is valentine's day so
generally forces of attraction when
we're talking about valentine's day mean
people falling in love and what holds
them together
and he's so kind he loves me he's
brought me a flower of course i'm a
physicist so i have to look into it a
little bit more deeply than that we're
going to talk about um forces of
attraction and basically the forces
of nature there are four main forces
that we're aware of for fundamental
forces there's a strong force there's
what we call the weak force there's
gravity and there's electromagnetic
forces there could be more we're looking
for more we're always testing for them
but at the moment there are four
and
their gravity
why we stay on the earth why the moon
goes round the earth but actually it's
an
unbelievably weak force compared to the
force that stops me being able to push
my hand through this desk which is the
uh
interaction between the electrons the
electromagnetic force of the
electrostatic force
gravity is unbelievably weak gravity
right here we go
gravity in action
my first experiment on the
on 60 symbols i was trying to come up
with an analogy or an everyday example
to compare the magnitude of the
gravitational force to the magnitude of
the electromagnetic force because it's
it's really quite difficult to get
across just how weak gravity is compared
to that electromagnetic force and so if
we if we take this petal which i've
taken off the rose let's say it's about
a gram it's about a gram weight so we
drop it down gravitational force tracks
it down um
to get the ratio of the magnitude of the
gravitational force to the
electromagnetic force you'd have to
you'd have to compare the weight of this
to the weight of and i hope i remember
this correctly 4 million billion billion
billion air buses so the weight of 4
million billion billion billion air
buses compared to the weight of this
petal
is the same as the magnitude or the
difference between or the ratio between
the electromagnetic force and the
gravitational force it's that much
different the force is so much different
then there's
electromagnetism electromagnetism is
why the sun and the light that we're
seeing from uh not from the sun here but
from from our um
light bulbs up there
and uh also they know the light that's
coming off the the petals here and that
we can see their electromagnetic rays
their light that's coming to us
the key thing for me
is the chemical bonds so it's the
electromagnetic force that what's that's
what dictates um the bonds in this it's
what dictates the color it what it's
what dictates the stiffness it's what
dictates the sort of feel of it it's it
dictates everything those
electromagnetic interactions are the
essence of this of this rose
they they define for me and i think from
pretty well old physicists define what
it means how do things experience force
one on the other at first we thought
that it was an instantaneous process you
see something over here
and something over there and they're
attracted by gravity which pulls
instantaneously together or you'll see a
charge here and another charge over
there and they're pulled together
instantaneously
and the idea came about that you could
actually think of the charge over here
producing electric field and the field
pulling it in
and then later on it was realize that
this electric field can't get from here
to there instantaneously because it's
can only travel at the speed of light so
this is giving out a little bit of
information which is arriving there a
little bit later because it can only
travel at the speed of light and this
thing gets pulled in bit by bit in that
way so it's not instantaneous the
attraction between objects we've got the
weak force next let's do the weak force
because they think i think gravity and
electromagnetism people are quite
familiar with but the the weak force
maybe not so much the weak force acts
within an atom in fact it acts within a
nucleus of an atom that the very small
center central region of an atom
but it's fundamental it accounts for why
the sun burns some some
objects are red
are radioactive they'll decay and in in
decaying they might emit a particle and
they'll emit some radiation
and that process the force that's
responsible for that the interaction
responsible for it is the weak
interaction but it only acts on very
small scales and and then there's the
the big forces of
the strongest of them in the sense of
their effect on individual particles and
that's the strong force and the strong
force also acts within the uh
the center of a nucleus of an atom
and it's what stops as exploding and
that's what's holding the the nuclei
together
but
the and other than sort of keeping the
atoms together so making this sure this
thing doesn't explode due to the
repulsion of the
of the of the protons
really i neglect the strong force i
don't really care about the strong force
it's not something that influences my
experiments it's not something i have to
consider in my experience indeed in the
first year module i'm currently teaching
about the interactions of atoms and
molecules i put up the four fundamental
forces is strong weak gravity
electromagnetic put a big x too strong
big x true weak big x true gravity and
say we're only going to concentrate on
the electromagnetic forces the roses got
is made of carbon there's carbon in
there each carbon atom has i think of
order six protons
and from school we learned that the
proton has a positive charge and we know
that things have got the same charge
actually want to repel like charges
repel
so in the in the center of a nucleus
which is incredibly small distance
around 10 about one fermi it's called 10
to the minus 15 meters that's note point
and then
14 what zeros and a one meter
within that there's six protons all
pushing apart
so they don't want to stay there but
they do stay there fortunately because
that's what keeps the stem here uh nice
and solid and and it's the
it's the strong force within there that
actually overcomes
the the repulsive nature of
electromagnetism within for the for
these protons and binds them together so
we have these
four forces
completely different
and yet one of the great goals of
physics of of theoretical physics is
actually to unify these forces it's
actually to try and describe them as one
and there's been a degree of success in
that in fact faraday
back in the 19th century showed that
electricity and magnetism were two two
manifestations of the same force and
they called electromagnetism
and then in the late 60s and early 70s
people began to show that you could have
electromagnetism and the weak force
they could be represented
as the same underlying force and that
was called the electro weak interaction
and that was confirmed
experimentally at places like cern in
near geneva the particle accelerator
and then people started thinking about
what about the strong force could we
introduce the strong force with the weak
force and the electromagnetic force
and and that's been shown to be the case
in what's known as quantum
chromodynamics qcd where you can
represent all of these three forces
under the same mathematical umbrella
they described them all beautifully
but gravity is proving most difficult
and that remains to be the the the goal
to try and also bring gravity into into
this big picture